let me tell you guys a story
I told this before we I was in Frederick
Frederick whatever pounds in Maryland
and uh this was during lockdown it was
during mask mandates and all that stuff
and I went to get sushi and uh uh I was
with my girlfriend we walked into the
sushi restaurant we were standing
probably about five or ten feet from it
from a two-person table and we walked in
and I was like two and then they looked
at me and said you need to wear a mask
and then I looked around at everyone
everyone aside from the staff no masks
yeah and I was like um excuse me like
nobody's wearing masks I'm like well
they're eating and I was like oh yes I'd
like to eat as well and I said no but
put a mask on and I said well are you
serious like but they're not wearing
masks right now like I'll just sit down
is that okay and they're like no put the
mask on yeah and then I said you want me
to wear a mask for 10 seconds are you
serious and they all go everyone turns
and goes yes and I was like I'm leaving
like what is wrong with their brains
dude there was 50 people people sitting
around with no masks on you and I
thought you know I was in Frederick
recently I'm walking around I got a
coffee and I thought I made a mistake
that day you know what I should have
done I should have been like oh I'm
sorry I should have taken the mask and
just gone like this and just pulled it
and held it right in front of my face
floating about an inch away
and then just you know just just okay
I'll sit down and you want me to sit
down I'll sit down and go okay
I should have grabbed a napkin or
something at that point just cover your
mouth with it put your hand over your
face
yeah it's gonna do the same thing your
hand in the napkin is going to do the
same thing that a cloth mask would do I
thought about that when I was there and
I said you know when you go to West
Virginia they they did the Statewide had
Mass mandates for stuff but like nobody
was really following it it was kind of
funny and so I just avoided any place in
West Virginia that actually had a sign
asking for Mass I was like this is
stupid what did your restaurants do if
you don't mind me asking and did you
guys have to comply with the Plexiglas
that went up in price very uh
significantly during this whole uh
shenanigan nonsense uh theater that we
had to go through I've got a warehouse
full of plexiglass right now I mean it's
like their Plexiglas was in such demand
I ended up having to meet some guy
behind a 7-Eleven at 2 30 in the morning
he bought it out of the back of a
Cadillac I mean it was like no I'm
kidding but Plexiglas was it was so hard
to get it was virtually impossible and
we we left it up to the consumer and we
had people leave because they were like
they're not wearing masks but we just
let people decide what they wanted to do
but now that we're talking about masks
let me throw a couple facts out there
three million masks are discarded
worldwide every single minute masks are
made of polypropylene all of those masks
all of them end up in the ocean guess
what polypropylene breaks down into
microplastics so in California okay I
have to now they are mandating masks
again in Los Angeles so I have to wear a
mask recently yeah yeah wow yeah they
reinstated The Mask so they're mandated
indoors all right that mask is going to
end up in the ocean it's going to be
microplastic going to end up in our
entire food system and it's going to
kill sea life now alternatively I if I
ask for a straw and a straw is given to
me both me and the person who gave it to
me get a fine if it happens twice it's
criminalized and you can go to jail for
it wow so you can't get the straw
because you got to save sea life but you
have to wear the mask to kill sea life
call me fornia I have maybe this is a
hot take but I think that kovid
particularly is spreading and has been
spreading through the food supply not
through the air or maybe a spread it has
been spraying through the air as well
ice cream Theory
now from a Daily Mail as of December 3rd
broccoli and raspberries could give you
coven Health experts warn after learning
the virus can live on popular foods for
as long as a week I think that's I think
that's a little bit of a fear-mongering
protected on Peppers spam bread crust
and cheese for several days hold on just
pop the story Ian's not wrong broccoli
and Rose
on top of ice cream
the title is suggestive saying it could
not that it would it's been found it's
detected covet on Pepper's ham bread
crust and cheese
uh I mean absolutely the writing is on
the wall uh from from Newsweek covid-19
has now been found in ice cream uh this
is from you thought you got January
I think that it lives in on food but but
they don't want to cause panic but the
thing is that that could be
scientifically true but we know that
covet is a respiratory so you have to
breathe it in if it lives on the food
it's an active culture but if you
swallow it then it's killed in your body
I think it lives on pineapple pizza I
mean you could smell the food so it's
like no one should ever order a
pineapple pizza exactly if you smell
because it has it on it it's okay very
important well if I could ask you you
just talked a little bit about the
regulations in California I couldn't
imagine I I think it would be my worst
nightmare in my life to open up a
business in California what what was it
like operating business there what are
some of the more insane regulations that
you have to go through that the people
don't know about and well keep in mind
too and it's different in different
parts of California because everybody's
like why are you still living there well
number one because somebody's got to be
fighting in enemy territory and number
two there are certain areas where
there's reason and there's logic and
rationale Orange County being one of
them uh Los Angeles is incredibly
difficult when it comes to opening a
business but I'll tell this one story
right so as I had mentioned I started as
a food truck in 2011 and then grew the
Enterprise I had no money to start the
first brick and mortar I bought this Old
Bagel Shop it was a hole in the wall but
it was a turnkey situation the landlord
was going to take a chance on me and I
think we ended up raising like seventy
thousand dollars to open this and I had
no money after that not even a penny
right when we're about to open we do the
kind of final walk through with health
and they go where's your grease
Interceptor the underground one right
and I said oh it's well we're
grandfathered in because I bought the
lease it's an above ground one they said
yeah but that kind of Grandfather piece
is going to go away in a couple years so
just put the underground one and I'm
like look I can't that's 20 25 000
they're like yeah we don't care you got
to do it so I'm about to open so I have
to take out a high interest loan that I
paid off like 14 years later at you know
39 interest compounded every minute but
the point is twenty five thousand
dollars the day before my business is
supposed to open when there wasn't even
a specific regulation it was more just
well it's going to have to happen even
though we were told everything was going
to be okay that story kind of represents
California were they expecting a bribe
because it seems like a lot of mafioso
like people run a lot of these
regulations and they kind of expect some
money underneath the table just to not
Implement whatever made up nonsense they
want to implement that's more jersey
style Jersey is is is and I'm from
Jersey so um I know that in California
it's just an aptitude in California it's
the it's you're feeding the bureaucracy
and the bureaucracy feeds the
bureaucracy it's kind of like a um you
know a beast that eats itself do you
just love it there is that why you're
still there
um it is beautiful place my wife was
born and raised there and my kids love
it so you know I uh where are you not
you're in a not Long Beach near Long
Beach Huntington Beach it's such an
amazing area I mean it's gorgeous it is
Manhattan Beach Long Beach Venice up and
down the boardwalk you can ride your
bike I highly recommend everybody get a
chance to visit at some point in their
life it's so amazing but
why do you hate pineapple pizza uh it's
too wet so it drizzles on the pizza I
would do like a pineapple salsa with
jalapenos to finish the pizza but a
roast but roasted and sweet and sticky
pineapple releases way too much moisture
and then it it kills the dough if it
sits there too what if the pineapples
diced up super fine well in the in the
form of like a salsa that hasn't been
cooked because then it won't release all
that moisture what about dehydrated
pineapple too much work no I actually I
like that this could be the compromise
that people have been asking for I you
know it's funny I did I said I would
never eat pineapple pizza
um and I forget what I what it was about
and then Newsmax reached out to me and
said well you said you wouldn't if x
happens so we want to do a live shot of
you eating pineapple pizza on TV so we
so we actually did it that was the only
one and well the second time and last
time I'll eat pineapple pizza do you do
you use seed oils uh I I try not to
although seed oils are hidden in a lot
of different yeah different places
they're everywhere that's where I go
back to the omega-6s so seed oils are
bad because you have this this
balance of omega-6 fatty acids that
leads to inflammation and hypertension
and a lot of other issues so if you
actually eat more Seafood you can
theoretically balance out that that
inflammation and have a couple seed oils
sorry like what about all the gluten
stuff right you know a lot of people
don't want to eat it I've actually you
know so I cut out sugars about a year uh
it's been like a year now it's crazy I
can't believe how long it's been yeah
and I lost a lot of weight but I cut out
rice too and I've been adding uh so I
went like way down to like no carbs then
I then I sort of tried things next I
remember uh like Michaela Peterson and
Jordan Peterson we're talking about
nothing but meat and they said well the
very least an Elimination Diet you get
rid of everything and then slowly try
things and see which one bothers you and
ultimately what ultimately what I found
is it's not so much eating sugar too
much obviously messes me up but on the
days that I'll eat bread the next day I
feel foggy and groggy
yeah I mean it all affects you 90 of
your neurotransmitters are in your
intestines right so obviously what we
eat is related to our brains that's why
people with irritable bowel syndrome
take your uh antidepressants because
that's they're they're one of the same
yeah and this is why a lot of uh the gut
irregate a lot of the gut problems are
correlated with a lot of people taking
your ssris and antidepressants as well
and and there there's been something
happening within our food industry that
is absolutely incredibly worrisome
especially when it comes to chronic
diseases that are becoming more and more
common obesity obesity rates have gone
up 30 in the last 20 years meanwhile
meanwhile our calorie intake didn't
really change that much so people have
to start asking themselves What What In
the world's really going on here what do
you make of all this what do you think
from being inside the industry is
responsible for a lot of us yeah it is
it's what the food is made up of it's
obviously the food deserts too you look
in a lot of these inner cities they have
no access to Whole Foods real foods so
they're eating empty calories
um so even if you look at it on a kind
of a calorie by calorie base basis
there's there's superfoods and there's
effective calories and then there's just
kind of empty calories that that
ultimately affect the mind which is what
probably what you were feeling the next
day and that's a common that's a common
feeling I think that people come down on
on this notion this gluten-free movement
as being just this kind of California
hippie left-wing thing I think there is
a genuine
um issue in our food system that's
leading people to have more sensitivity
to gluten is what it is I mean that
could be conspiratorial and I could pin
it to certain vaccines or I could just
say it's the you know preponderance of
of hidden chemicals in our food
specifically glyphosate I'm sure you
guys have oh yeah oh yeah all the time
they use it as a desiccant on wheat if
your wheat's not organic uh what they'll
do is they'll spray it on there
throughout the course of the wheat's
life to prevent I think it's a fungicide
or is it a is it a herbicide it's an
herbicide Roundup yeah it's to make sure
Bill Gates favorite uh pesticide but
then they go in right before they're
about to harvest it and to dry out the
wheat they hit it with Roundup again is
a desiccant and then they harvest it
really quick quick that's disgusting and
now Bill Gates is making super glycer
fate as of course the glycophate and and
the the bacteria resistance is starting
to build up against it and not being as
effective so now they're doing a
stronger version of glycophate and this
is the latest corn video that Bill Gates
kind of rolled out there recently with
him sucking down on the corn cob uh and
and and when children you know dancing
and uh and singing behind you know you
know what they originally use glyphosate
for and it started in the Reagan
Administration and they actually were
using it they would spray Colombian
cocaine um Farms with the glyphosate to
kill it and then it would sadly it would
leach into the water system with leach
into the surrounding communities which
are like smaller communities or
indigenous communities and then they saw
10 15 years later a lot of those people
started developing different Cancers and
all these Health ailments but it was
used by the U.S government to stop it
was part of the drug war yeah now it's
in all of our food yeah I'd rather have
the cocaine in our food
okay
that was another another chemical well I
don't want to talk right now there's a
whole bunch of garbage that they put in
uh in our food and everybody eats it
that's another thing too we we have
these glass bottles we used to we have a
bunch of those plastic water bottles I
see you're drinking over there but we
also have uh we started buying a bunch
of glass bottles to get away from the
plastic ones because of the phthalates
the the pcbs with the p the pfas or
whatever there's just like it's crazy I
kind of feel like we look back on
history and we're like did you know they
used to drink Mercury to to deal with
syphilis or whatever in 50 to 100 years
they're gonna be like could you imagine
they were actually using plastic for
their food how messed up is that it's
such a good point you are entirely
correct we will so much of what we're
doing right now we're gonna look back on
and be like isn't that crazy which is
funny because during covid everything
was just agreed upon as pure fact you
can't question it trust the science okay
so let's start I just want to bring up
one more Point especially when it comes
to micro Plastics that are now being
found in people's lungs and blood this
is something that of course is also a
huge disrupter of your hormone system
and this is why a lot of people think
that sperm levels and testosterone
levels have gone down so so much
dramatically within the last few years
is there I mean there's no way of
stopping it China just keeps getting all
the plastic dumping it into the ocean uh
the United States just essentially just
started doing the same thing
um The Masks again lots of plastic just
being thrown out there people breathing
it in sucking sucking all the plastic
down there is there a way of of even
avoiding this plastic I mean we try to
do uh you know glass bottles but at the
same time everything else is in plastic
all the food is wrapped in plastic all
the cookware is is laced with plastic
all the things are non-stick plastic is
there is there a way of avoiding any of
this craziness because like I'm just I'm
just looking at everything that's
happening I'm like I mean there's no way
of stopping it dude I mean I use bamboo
to cook with my food Etc and you can use
like a skillet you know you can there's
things you can do that are like oh yeah
I have a cash iron skillet as well but
then you know the food comes packaged in
plastic right that's right no I don't
understand don't understand yeah am I
being too paranoid here or do you like
what are you seeing from your
observation you know I don't know
um in terms of where it's coming from in
that particular scenario right so if we
have all these micro Plastics that are
in our lungs that's we're breathing that
in so is that does that come from food
does it come from cooking uh does it
come from heat I just I have no idea I
mean it's clearly it's an issue
um but it's you know it's one of those
issues that's used as a hammer in
certain circumstances and ignored in
other circumstances yeah I'll I'll put
it this way Luke um we just have to go
to farms uh I believe it was what like a
hundred years ago the average family
owned a cow or something like that like
cows were very common a family would
have the family cow when you wanted meat
there wasn't plastic but you had to go
to a farm you had to go to a butcher you
can still do those things it's just that
there's a convenient location with
plastic wrapped food for you and so we
just choose to go there but look man
we're lucky out here maybe even like
five miles away there's a farm a Farm
Stand it's a little building and when
you when you go in there get the meat
it's it's in like wax paper it's in like
you know Deli wrapped wax paper and then
they hand it to you it's frozen and you
bring it home and you you peel a sticker
It's Paper open it up farm fresh meat
right there on the spot nope no plastics
grass-fed good stuff a lot of the papers
have plastic in them a lot of the
receipts have plastic in them my dream
now is to have a cow sorry Ian you had
something else you wanted I'm wearing
plastic glasses on my face it's pretty
gross probably leaching into my head as
I'm speaking I've been thinking that a
little esoterically like if the Earth is
an organism and they say like it'll if
it doesn't like the life on it it'll
kill it all with like a flood like it'll
flood itself and wipe out all the life
that's been poisoning its surface or
it'll bring an asteroid a meteoroid or
something I think also what the Earth
would do this is obviously it's kind of
somewhat silly to think of the Earth as
a living organism but let's just say it
is that it would wipe out Humanity by
making it sterile and we're kind of
doing that to ourselves with plastics
and hormones and chemicals herbicides in
our water supply it's it's decreasing
the fertility rates and so it's it's
another way to wipe out a species is
through infertility I'd never thought of
that before we don't need a flood or an
asteroid this time we just got to be
really careful about what we consume but
I mean good question Luke I think maybe
the future is
graphene getting away from these weird
oil-based carbons and trying to make
something a little more stable like
diamond packaging is worse than all the
other Plastics and leeches even more and
then it goes into our bloodstream you
got to find ways for it not to Leach
that's key like I don't know if you had
like like malleable Diamond plastic like
if it was like diamond pure carbon and
it was like crumpleeble diamond if that
would not Leach I mean I think you could
find ways to not leech could we be
proactive though and actually make the
packaging out of testosterone oh
something edible or like vitamin C we're
thinking on the defense here we gotta be
we got there there's a there's a store
uh not far away from here that the they
print their receipts on like vitamin C
receipts and there's no plastics so I
didn't see yes vitamin C uh moms moms
supermarkets do that yeah the the
receipts are not made of out of plastic
they're like hey we have vitamin C uh um
receipts here you can eat it
um I asked him if I could they're like
no but uh you know the plastic
especially from the receipts it does
Leach does have they're like yes your
purchase record and we'll see if we let
you out of the store but every time I'm
there I'm like hey this is pretty cool
that you guys are doing this um the
receipt's like particularly bad or they
have cancer-causing chemicals in them is
that the reason why well they're they're
uh made out of plastic that leeches
right I got to see some documents on
this vitamin C receipt because this is
sounding yeah I've never heard of that
you got to show up to Mom's uh the
supermarket in there right now is it
like a huge chain moms I think so
they're pretty great though yeah I like
going there got Farm Fresh Cream for my
coffee real grass-fed stuff expires real
quick like it's supposed to so just to
ask you because you're in the food
industry did you notice the the level of
food kind of going down throughout the
throughout the last few years like do
you see the quality being an issue or
you know what's the kind of inside
baseball when it comes to procuring a
lot of food for your restaurants yeah
well the trajectory has already been on
a downward spiral just in general in
terms of quality of food and it follows
look at the quality of any everything
right
um but the uh over the since the
pandemic Yeah it's gotten really bad
because number one the supply chain
issues number two our relationship with
China and I think people don't realize
how much we rely on other countries for
our food so our food system is not just
incredibly vulnerable and it's not
domestic but it's also I mean it's
questionable when you're getting food
from another place that you don't know
how they're harvesting raising rearing
the husbandry behind their food so yeah
the answer is of course take the extra
time that's a great point that Tim makes
is that you if you take the extra time
you actually can go find that butcher
you know that that fish monger whoever
it is to actually try and understand
where your food is coming from I know it
sounds like a cliche from a wholesale
perspective it's much easier for me as a
restaurateur because I can kind of cut
out a couple kinks in that chain of
custody but consumers can do that too
and this is the point I've been making
since inflation has gotten so bad it's
incumbent upon consumers to create a
relationship with a restaurateur not
just this isn't kind of self self
filling here because then you can
piggyback on their orders and their
products I love it when customers come
to me and say hey can you throw five
extra pounds on the order of broccoli
that you're getting and then I buy more
which gives me better economies of scale
my customer gets raw products at a much
lower you know value which puts more
money in their pockets that they
hypothetically could spend at my
restaurant or another Community
restaurant I mean that's the notion of
comparative advantage and you know what
that's doing is actually cutting out the
Walmart to the world that's cutting out
a lot of these other businesses I think
someone should develop an app to
facilitate customers piggybacking off of
restaurant tours purchases I completely
agree well there's also a lot of
monopolies that I think cause a lot of
problems in the industry I think it's
estimated that there's only 10 companies
that produce 90 of the food in the
United States and when you have so many
few uh big multinational Industries
controlling a lot of this uh you know
many times profit is incentivized over
of course offering a product that's
actually good or healthy or actually
going to be helping people in the long
term because a lot of the times it's not
incentivized to do so and I think also
behind the scenes there's a bigger
agenda to try to poison people with the
release of glycophate with the release
of seed oils making them a lot cheaper
with government subsidies knowing that
the end result will be more unhealthy
people which will be dependent on
government and therefore government is
doing this according to my own personal
opinion isn't uh like the wrong majority
of food from Cisco from all these
restaurants yes Cisco U.S Foods um you
know they're two of the biggest players
out there actually their their merger
was broken down by an Anti-Trust lawsuit
which is surprising um but then it would
have been just one Behemoth um running
all the food but how does that work what
does Cisco do are they a distributor or
they're like they're a wholesaler and a
distributor so what they're going to do
is they're going to aggregate all the
products and then they're going to
distribute it to all the restaurants
venues you name it um so it's just
massive purchasing power wow yeah I mean
it is huge and and it's it's for me
um you know when it comes to trying to
grow a business and scale good I
consider what we were doing from a
sustainability perspective a good
business and using the little guys
because we mandated that as part of our
franchise system it was virtually
economically impossible to do so and to
avoid the ciscos and the US Foods of the
world and ultimately my franchisees
ended up using those guys and I couldn't
stop them from using it because you
can't force them to lose money right and
then the big guys win they always do
what's the new lawsuit you said if your
franchisee does something Elite like I
didn't get the full story but what is it
it's called The Joint employer it's
called The Joint employer Rule and it
was actually set forth during the Obama
Administration it was overturned during
the Trump Administration and then it was
put back in place
um under the new abide Administration
and what it basically conjects is that
if you are a franchisor let's say I sell
a franchise to you you're all the way
out here you're running the franchise
and you're mistreating your employees
I've just licensed you my brand I don't
run your business you run your business
I have absolutely nothing to do with it
let's say you short pay one of your
employees your employee sues you they
sue me too I'm in the lawsuit even
though I have nothing to do with it it
pierces that corporate veil between the
franchisee and the franchisor giving
responsibility to the bigger guy that
doesn't sound like a functional system
yeah and originally it was set forth by
McDonald's it was a McDonald's lawsuit
because they said that McDonald's was
trying to stop the unions from working
with local franchisees and then there
was a lot of issues in lawsuits they
went after the whoever the had the
biggest okay so certain level of
Corporations well anyway that's an
interesting conversation do you how did
you guys navigate like because you said
2011 is when you opened your first food
cart and so it's 11 years later you got
60 60 restaurants uh so it was yeah ten
years later we had 40 couple different
kinds how did you create such explosive
growth was it my my hopefully what
you're going to say as good ingredients
but tell me about like what did you
prioritize to get there well actually it
was pretty simple formula so what we
said is my the whole entire mission was
to get people to eat more Seafood but
more of the right types of seafood so we
were sourcing 100 percent sustainably
caught raised Farm seafood and then all
of our ingredients we were the first
four star Green certified restaurant we
were actually kind of at the Forefront
of green
um so I you know I'm like that that that
um you know kind of weird hippie space
but we sent that we we stuck with our
message we're true to it we weren't
green washing ninety percent of the
businesses now that use all that
language they're not true to it we're
true to it and sustainability tastes
better right and that's what people need
to realize is that at higher quality
when it comes to food and sustainability
it does actually taste better and then
that was it I mean it's a real simple
formula just also good food I'll say one
thing you know Papa John's better
ingredients the company did Papa John
dirty but actually look at their
ingredients and it's it's true and I you
know I love this I looked at the the
ingredients for like Pizza Hut their
crust has Splenda in it yeah yeah why
then you look at dominoes and dominoes
isn't as bad but they've got you like
you'll see like words you can't
pronounce but then you look at like Papa
John's and it's like whole wheat water
yeast you know the sauce tomatoes sugar
you know the cheese part skim milk
whatever it's like wow really is like
very very basic stuff we got these
protein bars the epic epic protein bars
it's just meat got them because the
ingredients it's like beef garlic
paprika and then the only thing that's
weird is like the lactic acid thing I'm
like I know what that is it doesn't
freaked me out and it's like it's pretty
good stuff man thanks for watching this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time